vamos a hacer un pequeño repaso de la
energía potencial y en especial de la
energía potencial gravitacional porque
en este vídeo vamos a hacer un poco más
precisos digamos que aquí tengo un
objeto que tiene una masa m y quiero
cambiar su posición en la dirección
vertical estamos suponiendo que estamos
sobre la tierra donde el campo
gravitacional es g y tenemos un cambio
en la dirección vertical del talle de
modo que esta es la nueva posición del
objeto de masa m así que cuál es su
cambio en energía potencial
gravitacional bueno esto ya lo hemos
visto antes nuestro cambio en la energía
potencial debido a la gravedad
va a ser la masa de nuestro objeto
multiplicada por el cambio gravitacional
multiplicado por nuestro cambio en la
posición en la dirección vertical delta
que es igual a m porque por del taller
esto está bien pero hay un par de cosas
en las que podemos ser un poco más
precisos o que podemos pensar en este
vídeo una vez que supusimos un campo
gravitacional constante esto está bien
si estamos cerca de la superficie de un
planeta y otra vez que estamos haciendo
todo de manera relativa pero hay alguna
manera de obtener un número
y sobre cuál es la energía potencial de
la habitación al bueno para pensar en
eso regresemos a la ley de gravedad de
newton la cual nos dice que si tenemos
dos objetos uno de masa m1 y otro de
masa m2 y la distancia entre sus centros
de masa es r entonces la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad que actúa desde el
centro de un objeto en dirección del
otro y tiene una componente de igual
magnitud en sentido opuesto desde el
otro objeto va a ser igual a la
constante gravitacional multiplicada por
el producto de las dos masas dividido
entre la distancia al cuadrado otra
manera de pensar en esto es que si
quisiéramos conocer el campo
gravitacional creado por m2
entonces dividiríamos a ambos lados / m
1 de modo que si dividimos ambos lados
entre m 1 obtenemos que el campo
gravitacional en realidad no es
constante sino que es igual a la
constante gravitacional multiplicada por
m2 la masa del objeto que genera el
campo gravitacional dividido entre r
cuadrada así que esto en realidad puede
ayudarnos a obtener una fórmula
absoluta para la energía potencial
gravitacional podemos decir que la
energía potencial gravitacional y ésta
suele escribirse con una g mayúscula es
igual a la masa del objeto llamémosla m
1 multiplicada por el campo
gravitacional o bien mayúscula
multiplicada por la masa del objeto que
crea el campo dividido entre r cuadrada
multiplicado por la altura por arriba
del centro de masa a la cual se
encuentra el objeto que genera el campo
gravitacional y eso cuánto es bueno si
este objeto fuera la tierra veríamos a r
como que tan lejos del centro de masa
estamos así que multiplicaríamos lo
anterior por r una r y una de las r al
cuadrado se cancelan al final tenemos un
subíndice g igual a m uno en mayúscula
m2 entre r ahora una cosa en la que
debemos pensar es cuál es el campo
gravitacional cuando r tiende a infinito
cuando r se hace muy muy muy grande el
campo gravitacional tiende a cero pero
al mismo tiempo mientras más nos
alejamos mayor debería ser la energía
potencial y la manera en la que pensamos
acerca de esto es poner
un signo negativo en frente de la
fórmula y todo funciona así que vamos a
reescribir esto la energía potencial
debida a la gravedad se puede escribir
como menos la constante gravitacional
multiplicada por la masa del primer
objeto multiplicada por la masa del
segundo objeto dividido entre r y pueden
ver que esto se ve muy parecido a la ley
de gravedad de newton pero la diferencia
es que tenemos un signo de menos
enfrente de la constante gravitacional y
en lugar de dividir entre r cuadrada
solo dividimos entre r pero esto es muy
muy valioso porque ahora tenemos un
sentido absoluto de lo que es la energía
potencial gravitacional y satisface
todas las propiedades que necesitamos
que a medida que nos alejamos tendremos
un aumento en energía potencial
gravitacional porque se va a ser menos
negativa pero al mismo tiempo cuando
tendemos a infinito a medida que r se
hace muy grande la energía potencial va
a tender a cero hasta aquí llegamos en
este vídeo en próximos vídeos vamos a
aplicar esto